To start with, we're going to look at how we take the logic for our demo dancer and put that into a standalone blueprint.
This is going to look relatively similar to what we have here in our level blueprint.
We'll kind of be copying this out and rebuilding these references since it will be its own self-contained blueprint actor.
So we'll come down here, we'll right click and add a blueprint class of type actor.
We'll call this BP session dancer.
Open it up and we have a nice blank blueprint here.
We can add a skeletal mesh component.
We can set the skeletal mesh asset to our session demo dancer.
There we go.
And we will set the use animation blueprint. We'll leave that to true.
And we will set our animation blueprint class to the session demo dance.
Beautiful.
Now, over here in the event graph, we are going to copy in the code that we can reuse from our level blueprint,
which is these.
And let's get over here.
We can delete this, copy these in and take the sequence out.
We don't need that. We'll get our skeletal mesh.
There we go. Get our animation instance, cast it to our ABP demo dancer and call dance toggle if that succeeds or not to demo dancer.
We'll print that out if it fails.
I deleted our event begin play, but I would actually like that back.
So that just like we did with our cube that spins around, we can enable input on this actor.
And we just need to make sure we have a reference to the player controller.
Excuse me. And we'll make sure that this spacebar is not consuming our input.
Awesome. Go ahead and close this spin cube here as well.
So the next thing we want to do, though, is get our stage here.
And it's a blueprint, its own blueprint.
Let's right click blueprint class actor BP session stage.
Open this up. We'll add a static mesh component.
We can set this to our look for stage.
We want session stage. This is the one with our separate materials compile.
And then once again here, we'll look for our stage pillars.
And we can actually find that here and drag it in maybe a little bit faster.
Awesome. So we'll save that. Come back here. We can delete this session stage.
Delete this animation blueprint. Delete this stuff.
We'll leave up here for now until we finish copying things over.
Including session stage. We want to come over here to our event graph.
Do our same enable input. Get the player controller.
Copy the space bar. Our flip flop. Our two variables.
And the nodes to change the parameter.
We'll bring that here. We'll then grab these.
And you'll notice, though, that even though we copied in these materials from our level blueprint,
we don't see them over here in our variables list for this specific actor blueprint.
What we can do is come over and right click. Simply create variable color MPC.
Right click. Create variable.
Make sure you click on the node itself and not the name of the node or the pin.
Create variable. Compile. And then we'll need to come in here again
to each of these and make sure we have the correct one.
So we can do this. There we go.
Fantastic. Now we can close that. Let's also unlink this without deleting everything.
It doesn't know where our old animation blueprint is, but that's OK.
Still compile. And then let's drag in our session stage.
Bring this up to 160. That's where we were.
Bring it back a little. Maybe over to the side.
Position ourselves up. OK, looking good.
And then our BP session demo dancer right on in here.
And now when we press play, everyone's dancing. We press space.
Everything works. But now we can reuse our session dancer and our stage
in as many different levels as we want, which gives us a lot more flexibility for our game.
And once again, these slides here just calling out the process
that we're going to go, you know, of getting everything linked up together.
You'll see here in this slide, though, we have our stage as a collection of separate objects.
And we'll actually get to that a little bit later after we look at the modeling tools in a future video.
In the next video, we'll look at how we can start leveraging more of Unreal Engine's unique features,
starting with Lumen real time global illumination and applying post-processing settings in our level to enhance the look and feel.